bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravie de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir pour ou contre la
corrida le débat est relancé par
l'insoumis aymeric Caron il défendra sa
proposition loi sur ce plateau dans un
instant débat passionnelles s'il en est
qui divise jusque dans les rangs de la
majorité présidentielle on en parle dans
un instant avec nos invités notre grand
témoin ce soir est philosophe et elle
s'attaque dans son dernier livre à la
question
omniprésente voire obsédante de
l'identité notre époque se fourvoie
selon elle dans un nouvel ordre
identitaire l'expression est forte
Juliette Funès publie le siècle des
égarés aux éditions l'Observatoire elle
sera avec nous dans la deuxième partie
enfin trois affranchis ce soir trois
parties pris et si on arrêtait avec
Hanouna Marco pommier a posé la question
aux députés habitués du plateau de C8
après les insultes de l'animateur contre
l'insoumis Louis Boyard le regard de
vincent Hugeux sur Donald Trump en route
pour une troisième candidature à la
Maison Blanche et puis les villes de
demain avec FCF tel seront-elles moins
bétonnées pour sauver le climat voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti pour la
corrida
bon soirée Caron bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir c'est vous qui portez donc ce
combat contre la corrida à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez même écrit un petit
livre pour l'expliquer abolition le
titre est très fort vous nous
l'expliquerez chez Robert Laffont qui
paraît donc jeudi juste avant l'arrivée
c'est le 24 novembre dans les miss
cycles de ce texte proposition de loi
qui arrive demain en commission députée
insoumis membre de la France insoumise
mais du micro parti le vôtre
rappelez-nous
qui s'appelle la révolution écologique
pour le vivant la rêve qui est un parti
d'écologie radicale rêve donc merci
d'être là merci d'avoir accepté le débat
bonsoir jean-renais Cazeneuve et
bienvenue député renaissance du Gers un
territoire avec une tradition taurine
ancienne avec de nombreuses arènes avec
aussi des ferias vous défendez la
pratique de la corrida même si on le
verra votre groupe est divisé une partie
des députés Renaissance vont va voter on
verra ça le texte d'Aymeric Caron
bonsoir Tamara GA bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous représenter la SPA la Société
protectrice des animaux dont vous animez
le pôle juridique protection animale et
puis un éleveur de taureaux va nous
rejoindre dans un instant éleveur à
Nîmes il s'appelle Benjamin Cuillier et
il est président de l'Union de la
jeunesse taurine française voilà pour
les présentations vous avez compris il y
aura deux pour et de contre sur ce
plateau au milieu il y a Stéphane
blackovski bonsoir de service voilà
si j'ai bien compris ce texte est une
petite bombe politique
alors parlons d'abord tes stratégies et
de l'aspect politique de cette
proposition de loi si j'ai bien compris
si j'ai bien compris ça va faire 15 ans
à peu près que les Français sont
favorables à l'interdiction de la
corrida je vous laisse regarder
l'évolution des opinions sur le sujet
voyez
2007 on en était encore à 55 ans mais
depuis 15 ans le souci qu'on se fait
pour le bien-être animal a vraiment
augmenté donc là ce sont de la gif hop
nous dit 77% de gens favorables à
l'interdiction mais regardez si on la
question en précisant bien que la loi en
France interdit les actes de cruauté
entraînant la mort d'un animal sous
peine de 50 prisons 75000 euros d'amende
là c'est carrément et que la corrida
donc est la seule avec le combat de coq
à pénis là on passe à notre français sur
10 quand on connaît un peu le détail de
la loi alors question si la majorité des
Français soutiens l'interdiction alors
pourquoi le gouvernement s'oppose le
gouvernement s'oppose à la majorité des
Français mais croyez bien croyez bien
que c'est pas gaieté de cœur qu'on
s'oppose à l'interdiction de la corrida
prenons l'exemple d'oliveur c'est le
porte-parole du gouvernement je vous
promets que s'il écoutait que son cœur
lui alors franchement il irait pas
défendre la corrida parce que la corrida
il déteste ça on l'écoute
ne peut pas écouter que son cœur il doit
aussi écouter ces électeurs oui ça c'est
important les électeurs et interdire la
corrida forcément il y a certaines
régions où ça créerait en ce sont les
députés qui font remonter ça du terrain
vice mécontentement dans la population
dans certaines circonscriptions n'écoute
Patrick Vignal lui il n'est pas du Gers
il est de l'Hérault mais il est dans
l'essence
c'est quoi cette France de
l'interdiction vous savez dans les
territoires un peu difficiles comme les
miens je pèse mes mots les gens ils
attendent le plus rien de nous et
aujourd'hui en plus on va leur dire que
le dimanche ils pourront pas accéder
cette corrida cette corrida c'est
culturelle vous voyez il y a déjà assez
de gens en colère contre le gouvernement
pour pas rajouter les affiches une ado à
toutes ses colères d'ailleurs le but
c'est vraiment d'apaiser un peu le débat
donc on n'a pas mis Eric Dupond-Moretti
le ténor du barreau le celui qui aurait
médiatisé la question on a mis Dominique
fort à la place Dominique Faure
quelqu'un sait qui est Dominique fort
simplement je savais pas qui était
domicile ce matin c'est la secrétaire
d'État et la ruralité c'est bon
souligner qu'on a décidé de mettre
quelqu'un de moins médiatique un débat
compliqué parce qu'on disait la majorité
les fracturés sur le sujet alors
exactement la majorité divisée c'est pas
nouveau ça lui arrive assez souvent mais
là on peut pas lui en faire leurs
proches parce que en fait ça brouille
toutes les frontières politiques cette
question de l'interdiction de la corrida
on peut prendre par exemple un tweet de
Julien Oudoul priori député
aymerica on n'est pas forcément sur la
même ligne que Julien Oudot sur très peu
de sujets mais sur la corrida ou d'où
lui il dit maintenant mon la corrida je
suis pour l'interdiction donc c'est
pareil dans la majorité sont divisés je
vous montre une photo qui résume un peu
ça vous voyez c'était l'an dernier deux
amis des animaux qui visitent un refuge
Brigitte Bardot alors Gabriel Attal lui
il est au gouvernement donc bah il fait
terre son cœur il est il est contre
l'interdiction en revanche roderger elle
elle est à l'Assemblée et donc elle est
opposée elle veut interdire la corrida
elle ne veut pas suivre le gouvernement
et finalement alors cette proposition de
loi elle a une chance d'être adoptée ou
pas alors déjà il faut savoir si elle
sera examinée il y a un petit suspense
là-dessus je vous rappelle le principe
de la niche parlementaire une journée
consacrée en l'occurrence à LFI pour
faire passer différents textes comme le
texte de la proposition de loi d'Aymeric
n'est pas en première position il y a
toujours la possibilité qu'on n'est pas
le temps de le faire c'est un petit
risque mais je crois que surtout la
stratégie du gouvernement et de la
majorité quand elle veut contrer la
proposition de loi c'est d'insister sur
le côté quand même assez radical des
propositions d'Aymeric vous ai montré
que est-ce que ce type là va pas nous
entrer en entraîner par les choses qu'on
ne veut pas donc on voit le programme de
la rêve dont tu as parlé le député Caron
à l'instant et voyez que
la rêve voudrait que la loi interdit de
progressivement de tuer d'enfermer ou de
vendre un animal ce qui se signifie donc
à terme interdire la chasse interdire la
pêche interdire aussi l'élevage
évidemment c'est assez radical donc il
faudrait commencer par la corrida mais
jusqu'où allez-vous nous entraîner
députés Caron ben c'est l'objet du débat
merci beaucoup merci pour ce billet
mordant comme chaque soir Stéphane on va
commencer justement par la forme on
l'aura le débat de fond vous êtes là
pour ça mais sur la stratégie on sent
bien que la majorité un peu divisé sur
le sujet va vous attaquer sur ce que
vous incarnez un militant acharné de la
cause animale du bien-être animal vous
vous assumez ça a complètement vous
dites il y a déjà un aveu de faiblesse
ça veut dire que je suis en extrémiste
oui je l'ai deux j'assume et je
reconnais qu'un aveugle c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien que les adversaires les
opposants sont à court d'argument parce
qu'on va peut-être avoir l'occasion dans
passer en revue un certain nombre
encore
sur ce plateau il y a déjà eu un certain
nombre de débats et donc effectivement
on va aller chercher une nouvelle excuse
qui pourrait justifier le fait qu'on
n'ose pas voter pour l'abolition alors
le fait que j'ai des positions
antispécistes je m'en suis jamais caché
j'ai même écrit un livre qui porte ce
titre mon parti assume complètement ses
positions peut-être pour ceux qui nous
regardent l'idée que il y a des
concurrences d'espèces c'est juste pas
que on ne peut pas discriminer un
individu en raison de l'espèce à
laquelle il appartient ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut traiter les humains et les
animaux non humains de la même manière
ni tous les animaux la même manière ça
veut dire qu'il y a des discriminations
qu'on fait par exemple entre les cochons
et les chiens voilà ce genre de chose
c'est un peu complètement notre rapport
aux animaux mais en tant que en tant que
élu aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale
élu donc rêve au sein du groupe France
insoumise et au sein de la nupestre je
me suis engagé lors de la campagne sur
un programme et je ne dépasserai pas le
programme sur lequel les gens m'ont élu
et donc très clair par exemple
l'abolition de la godasse fait partie du
programme de la France insoumise ou des
écologistes et donc à l'Assemblée je
défendrai uniquement le programme sur
lequel j'ai été lu par ailleurs
l'argument est quand même et je
terminerai là-dessus assez fallacieux
d'imaginer que parce que en effet je
vois assez loin en termes de protection
animale j'aurais moi aymeric Caron tout
seul petit député la possibilité à moi
tout seul d'interdire la chasse
d'interdire aux gens de manger de la
langue et ainsi de suite soyons sérieux
d'accord vous vous n'êtes pas là pour
ouvrir la boîte de Pandore un mot quand
même sur la méthode c'est vrai qu'on
entend depuis quelques jours au fond la
question c'est qui porte le texte plutôt
que son objet Dominique Faure par
exemple on sent bien et là pour apaiser
elle est peu connue alors qu'on avait
compris que
Eric Dupond-Moretti rêvait dans des
Coudres lui un grand avis de féodanos de
la colère corrida pourquoi pourquoi ce
choix est-ce que vous avez peur de ce
débat non déjà si vous voulez le cette
ligne de fracture si vous voulez au sein
des parties et elle est sur tous les
parties on a l'air de dire qu'il y a que
Renaissance qui est divisé mais mais je
voulais aller aussi chez les LR Chez
Marco party socialiste elle est même à
la France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en 2017 disait qu'il fallait pas porter
ce sujet à l'Assemblée nationale c'était
absolument initiative
je vous ai écouté
je vous dis que il n'y a absolument
aucune contradiction aujourd'hui au sein
de la France insoumise les 75 députés
vont voter pour l'abolition voilà la
question est réglée est chez les Verts
c'est la même chose
dans la majorité des vous avez vous avez
il y a aussi le combat des coffres vous
expliquer pourquoi le combat des coques
y était pierre paru est-ce que c'était
pour justement faire en sorte que les
députés d'outre-mer pour qui c'est
quelque chose d'important
je vous ai écouté cher collègue donc
est-ce que est-ce que le donc il y a une
fracture qui est pas moi je suis ravi
et ça c'est ma position depuis le début
qu'il y a des sensibilités extrêmement
différentes au sein quand même président
de votre groupe le numéro de du groupe
roher vont voter peut-être je peux vous
dire quand même c'est qu'il y a une
grande majorité de députés de
renaissance qui voteront contre cette
PPL pour un certain nombre de raisons
c'est pas pour ou contre la corridor
quelques trucs presque il y a presque
anecdotique quand on voit son poids
aujourd'hui le nombre de taureaux
considéré mais c'est cette atteinte aux
libertés culturelle de nos territoires
c'est là et contre ça la majorité
s'opposera évidemment on y va sur le
bateau sur le fond il existe 10
départements torrents en France on va
les découvrir sur la carte en gros c'est
tout le Sud-Ouest et tout le sud-est une
partie du Sud-Est de la France en dehors
de ces 10 départements la corrida est un
délit reportage à la Feria de Istres la
circonscription du député rassemblement
national Emmanuel Tachet de la Pagerie
signé Clément Perrault attention
certaines images peuvent choquer
aux arènes d'Istres la noubiade a
commence
c'est un combat entre de jeunes taureaux
et de jeunes toreros
aux premières loges le député RN pro
corrida Emmanuel Tachet de la Pagerie et
André Viard ancien torero figure
incontournable d'une lobbythorin c'est
n'importe quel moment
peut prendre le dessus c'est ce que
alors
alors que le combat avance le taureau
reçoit plusieurs banderies et commencent
à saigner
le
sang que perd le taureau là
proportionnellement c'est moins que ce
que vous donnez si vous allez à la
Croix-Rouge pour faire un don c'est pas
beaucoup et les bandes c'est vraiment
minime alors quand on les regarde elles
font 5 cm mais le taureau il fait 400 kg
celui-là c'est impressionnant si on n'a
pas le courage de regarder la mort la
blessure en face mais la notion de
souffrance n'est pas la même pour
l'humain et pour le taureau
vient ensuite le point culminant d'une
corrida
les stockad
la mise à mort se fait d'un coup d'épée
placer le plus souvent entre l'omoplate
droite et la colonne vertébrale la mort
est rarement instantanée mais elle
intervient dans les secondes qui suivent
si le taureau a réussi son geste le
combat était juste
le taureau a été malheureux le taux
horaire euro a été aussi tout aussi
malheureux on l'a vu
je crois pas qu'on puisse appeler ça de
la torture en fait ça me choque pas si
c'est la question je crois pas que dans
les abattoirs les images soient aussi
agréable à voir vous avez remarqué que
le premier qui a été applaudit c'est le
taureau quand il est quand il a été
amené à la race et ça on ne le verra
jamais avec un animal l'abattoir le
taureau c'est comment il s'appelle aussi
d'où il vient on sait comment il a été
élevé et on le respecte
voilà justement d'où viennent ces
taureaux dans les grands espaces de
Camargue un élevage de Toulouse bravo
les torobrave une espèce venue d'Espagne
ces animaux vivent pendant quatre ans au
grand air avant de finir dans les arrêts
du Tour de combat
c'est pas c'est pas rentable pour la
viande parce que c'est au métro de temps
à faire du poids et ça nous coûterait
trop cher et c'est un animal et c'est
une race qui crée qui existe pour finir
dans la reine pour le combat elle peut
pas être utilisée pour autre chose
l'abolition de la corrida signifierait
donc la fin de ses élevages en France
les procuridas évoquent aussi des pertes
économiques importantes pour les villes
comme Arles ou Nîmes qui accueillent les
grandes feria
Jean René Cazeneuve il y a d'autres pays
qui ont interdit la corrida en Europe le
Danemark l'Italie quand on regarde ça
quand même il y a des sévices enfin il y
a de la cruauté est-ce qu'on peut nier
cette cette souffrance animale
est interdit aussi dans 35000 communes
de France donc c'est une exception et
donc est-ce qu'on veut maintenir cette
exception en culturelle tous les mois je
suis gascon je suis d'un pays de la
défériens des bandas la convivialité des
canards du foie gras des demoiselles et
des courses de taureau des courses
landaises et si vous m'enlevez une
partie de ça vous enlevez une partie de
ma culture Gascogne c'est ça sonne pas
et je ne veux pas que des Parisiens
m'expliquent ce que j'ai le droit de
faire ou de ne pas faire en Occitanie je
ne le comprends pas si vous voulez donc
aujourd'hui il y a 56 communes où c'est
encore possible d'avoir une tradition
taurine
il faut respecter ces gens-là il faut
respecter ce sont des taureaux de combat
élevés pour ça et je veux dire
probablement que leur dernière minute ne
sont pas très agréables personne ne le
nid mais ce sont des des taureaux qui
sont élevés pour ça si vous n'avez plus
de corrida vous n'avez plus ces taureau
alors je vous donne la parole dans un
instant mais je voudrais quand même
accueillir monsieur Guillet c'est ça
Benjamin crier vous êtes vous êtes
éleveur vous-même à Nîmes c'est ça et
vous représentez les les jeunes torins
on entend beaucoup ces arguments de la
Culture
du Patrimoine une forme d'art
d'esthétique et même d'économie dans
certaines régions de France est-ce que
est-ce que tout ça justifie une violence
qui existe ça c'est c'est un fait il y a
une violence contre le taureau qui meurt
à la fin mais c'est le sujet c'est c'est
tout à fait ça c'est plus la corrida
c'est l'exception culturelle l'exception
culturelle l'exception de la diversité
de culture moi quand j'enseigne
j'entends monsieur Caron par un
séparatisme ça me fait doucement rire ce
n'est pas l'argument on est un pays qui
s'est construit sur la diversité c'est
la diversité des gens les Gascons n'ont
pas envie de vivre comme les Bretons ni
comme les Alsaciens ni comme les Corses
mais est-ce que ma part respecter notre
diversité est-ce qu'on peut pas
respecter notre liberté c'est ça la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui alors
l'exception culturelle c'est intéressant
c'est nouveau aussi dans ce débat sur la
sur la corrida donc exception culturelle
versus souffrances animales comment
hiérarchissent aimerait
fort bien mais dans le cadre de la loi
commune
c'est à dire que c'est dans la
Constitution la France est une
République unie indivisible
pour les courses de taureau
ou une loi est faite si vous allez au
bout de mon propos si vous le permettez
donc c'est bien la seule activité en
effet qui au nom d'une exception
culturelle tolère quelque chose qui est
puni par ailleurs dans
95% des villes de France par donc on l'a
rappelé 50 prisons et 75000 euros
d'amende c'est la seule activité ou des
sévices reconnues sont autorisés pour
faire plaisir à une minuscule minorité
et puis surtout cette activité je suis
navré vous le dire est aujourd'hui
complètement contradiction avec notre
époque qu'à un moment on est toléré cela
parce qu'on n'avait pas conscience
effectivement des mots que l'on faisait
subir aux animaux qui sont dans les
arènes on peut tout à fait le comprendre
mais on a fait énormément de de progrès
en biologie en écologie neurosciences
vous exposez des des mots extrêmement
forts
souffre il n'a pas répondu non non vous
êtes parti sur la tradition et la fin
vous avez juste dit c'est un moment qui
n'est pas agréable je crois qu'il faut
arrêter les euphémismes c'est une séance
de torture non pas du tout voilà très
bien donc vous êtes donc dans une espèce
de négation de la réalité nous par
exemple on a auditionné des vétérinaires
dans le cadre de cette proposition de
loi qui nous ont tous confirmé cela
c'est à dire que ce qu'on fait subir
pendant les trois tercios lorsque
l'animal est d'abord attaqué par des
pics qui servent à travailler à
cisailler à taillader ensuite
effectivement il y a les banderies
ensuite il y a l'épée qui vient moi ça
me fait pas sourire mais je comprends
que vous puissiez je vous redonner la
parole mais je voudrais qu'on entend
souvent ensuite il y a les les à la fin
qui souvent fonctionnent pas la première
fois il faut s'y reprendre à plusieurs
reprises quand on voit le détail des
blessures qui sont infligées avec même
une méticuleuse idée qui interroge on ne
peut absolument qu'être absolument
repoussée par cette pratique aujourd'hui
alors ce recroqueviller derrière cette
histoire de culture de tradition pour
justifier ce qui est absolument
injustable par tout ailleurs en France
aujourd'hui en 2022 ça n'est plus
possible et je le répète vous l'avez dit
mais je le répète 9 Français sur 10
aujourd'hui veulent qu'on en finisse et
ça il faut que vous l'entendre
alors vous parleriez de torture aussi je
rappelle que vous représenter la SPA moi
je vais déjà redonner le cadre juridique
quand même la corrida s'inscrit dans un
article du code pénal qui est l'article
521 qui effectivement condamne les actes
de cruauté et ses vis graves donc
l'interprétation juridique même de ce
texte et que la corrida est un service
grave et un acte du cruauté qui
bénéficie d'une non-condation mais c'est
un acte de cruauté un service grave et
ça là-dessus juridiquement ce n'est plus
à discuter donc lorsque dans le
reportage j'entends que le l'animal ce
n'est pas de la torture déjà
juridiquement c'est faux
c'est seulement une exception à la règle
qui est qu'effectivement les actes de
cruauté sont on est d'après les chiffres
on a regardé plusieurs articles entre
170 et 200 corridas en France chaque
année dans les départements qu'on a
montré il y a à peu près 1000 taureau
mise à mort chaque année les chiffres
sont pas forcément voilà totalement
après je pense que fiable au taureau
prêt mais c'est des glandes de grandeur
monsieur Cazeneuve vous avez utilisé le
mot anecdotique moi ça me fait réagir
puisque la cruauté doit-elle être
anecdotique quand on combat la cruauté
on la combat dans son ensemble dans son
entièreté vous parlez d'exception
culturelle doit-elle permettre de
légitimer la cruauté moi je pense que
c'est ces questions là aujourd'hui qu'il
faut se poser il faut revenir à
effectivement la base qui est que le
texte de loi condamne la corrida en tant
qu'acte de cruauté sévis grave nous
avons des juridictions et je laisserai
la parole je vous en prie ont rendu des
décisions en rappelant que c'était
effectivement des actes de cruauté des
séquences des décisions qui datent de
2021 donc ils sont très mais qui ne
pouvait pas condamner au nom de cette
exception donc la vraie question à se
poser avec l'exception on en finit avec
la cruauté et surtout finalement
qu'est-ce que la société française veut
dans son rapport fait à la violence aux
animaux c'est-à-dire que au-delà de la
tradition au-delà effectivement de tous
ceux à quoi vous vous attachez la réelle
question de fond c'est cette légitimité
qui est donnée dans l'inconscient
collectif de torturer les animaux et
aujourd'hui les mots sont forts torturés
des animaux vous vous élevez des
taureaux vous connaissez bien la corrida
les feria est-ce que ce combat il est à
armes égales est-ce que on peut lire
quand on comme moi je découvre le sujet
mais je me rends compte que le taureau
il arrive dans l'arène parfois déjà
affaibli vous confirmez ça
pas du tout déjà celui dans quel sens
comment avec des sédatifs ou ils
passeraient du temps dans l'obscurité 24
heures avant je pose des questions je ne
fais pas
je vous engage à venir à découvrir et
voir comment ça se passe le but du jeu
de l'élevage pendant 4 ans c'est de
préparer un taureau le plus fort
possible donc quel est l'intérêt de la
moindre rire ça c'est des affabulations
et il suffit de venir voir comment se
passait un élevage ce que Monsieur Caron
n'a pas fait pour comprendre comment ça
marche comprendre ce qu'est l'élevage de
taureau comprendre ce qu'il tombe quelle
est sa nature profonde pourquoi c'est un
combattant pourquoi c'est un garant de
biosystème extraordinaire alors pourquoi
ça tient le lien entre l'élevage de
taureaux en Camargue par exemple et
l'écologie l'environnement et le climat
parce que la manière d'élever un taureau
aujourd'hui qui est à peu près d'un
hectare par bête garantit
en Camargue là où se trouve la plupart
des élevages la grande majorité la
conservation de biotope assez
extraordinaire la Camargue elle est
façonnée de la main de l'homme et elle
est très dure seule des races rustiques
peuvent vivre paturer si on n'avait pas
les taureaux on aurait des monoculture
et on aurait une perte de système sans
compter la perte d'une race quand même
puisque sans corrida plutôt c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre ce que les
antispécistes ne comprennent pas c'est
que les animaux ne sont pas les mêmes
les animaux des natures différentes un
chien n'est pas un taureau un chat n'est
pas un cheval ça vous êtes d'accord avec
cette idée là en fait c'est vous qui ne
comprenez pas l'antispécisme puisque les
spécisme n'ont jamais dit que tous les
animaux sont les mêmes et justement tout
notre fait qu'il faut reconnaître les
animaux qui sont réellement dans leur
réalité et dans leurs besoins propres à
chacune des espèces et donc jamais nous
n'avons dit qu'une souris est
l'équivalent d'une mouche qui serait
l'équivalent d'un taureau ou d'une
girafe en faisant des différences en
revanche
de publicité monsieur Caron où elle met
un chien avec un torero en disant est-ce
que vous feriez ça à votre chien tout
simplement parce que je me permets de
finir
puisque vous avez quelqu'un devant vous
qui monte sur le dos de son cheval tous
les jours et qui n'a jamais eu l'idée
farfelue de monter sur le dos de sa
poule reprendre mais je pense c'est ça
la vérité
ce que dit cette campagne est-ce que
pourrait dire aussi un antispéciste
comme moi c'est tout simplement que ce
que vous faites subir à un taureau est à
peu près équivalent à ce que
ressentirait en tout cas la douleur
ressentie par l'autoroute à peu près
quelle heure tu as celle que pourrait
ressentir un chien par exemple si vous
lui faisait faisait subir le même
traitement et ça ce sont des
vétérinaires qui nous l'ont confirmé
parce que ce sont des animaux qui ont
des systèmes nerveux à peu près
similaires même si après on va on peut
hein effectivement faire des polémiques
sur la professeur du cuir ainsi de suite
mais on en est pas là vous voyez une
question et on va la poser je vous donne
la parole juste après je redécanev alors
alors il nous attend depuis un moment et
je le remercie de d'avoir patienté
bonsoir Simon Casas vous êtes en ligne
avec nous depuis Madrid vous êtes une
grande voix des de la défense de la
corrida et vous êtes le directeur des
des arènes de Madrid en Espagne la mise
à mort pour bien comprendre vous qui
connaissez cette tradition
ancestrale ce qu'elle représente sa
symbolique la mise en mort est
indispensable dans la corrida est-ce
qu'il y a pas des pays qui gardent la
corrida sans cette fin tragique pour
l'animal
votre question est à la réponse à cette
question
est contenue dans de nombreux tiroirs
d'abord la question de la mort puisque
c'est la question que vous venez de
poser après la vie il y a la mort la
mort dans nos sociétés et le plus
souvent
occulté car c'est très difficile pour
l'humain de se confronter à sa finitude
nous allons tous disparaître la mise en
scène de la mort car la corrida est une
mise en scène de la mort aussi une mise
en scène qui n'est pas cruelle qui n'est
pas
qui n'agresse pas l'animalité de la
nature l'âme de l'animal mais au
contraire la glorifie car le taureau de
combat a un instinct de combat
précisément il n'est jamais forcé dans
l'arène à combattre les animaux tout à
l'heure on parlait de chien de chat ou
de tout ce que vous voulez lorsqu'ils
sont blessés lorsqu'il souffrent fuit le
taureau ne fuit pas défaut pourquoi il
ne fuit pas parce qu'il est animé par
son instinct de combat le taureau dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité est
appelée Mithra il s'appelait Alex
première lettre de l'alphabet hébreu qui
veut dire au taureau le taureau a
toujours été un mythe de fécondité et de
puissance un miroir pour lui-même une
référence dans culturelle historique qui
va bien au-delà des traditions qui est
transversale dans toutes les
civilisations je suis tolérant et je
comprends fort bien et je leur félicite
que Monsieur Caron puisse avoir de la
pitié pour les animaux mais les taureaux
de combat n'a pas besoin que l'on ait
pitié de lui il a besoin de combattre
parce que c'est dans sa nature si je
devais choisir un destin animal c'est le
taureau que je voudrais être de part la
qualité de vie qui lui est proposée il
est élevé pendant 4 5 ans dans position
optimale sanitaire de d'environnement
des meilleures pâturages et un jour il
va mourir comme vous allez mourir comme
je vais mourir et effectivement cette
meurt mort là devient un rite qui amène
le taureau qui l'élève dans une certaine
gloire ou plutôt dans une gloire le
temps le temps nous est compté
malheureusement c'est très intéressant
peut-être donnez-nous vous qui
connaissez bien cette histoire le sens
de cette cérémonie là quel est ce sens
et d'où vient-il quelle est la
symbolique de la corrida la symbolique
de la corrida c'est surtout pas un
combat j'entends le mot combat dans
l'esprit
de tous les acteurs de la corrida les
lever le torero le public le combat
n'existe pas c'est une fusion une union
entre l'humain et l'animal et l'animal
en fait circonstance était levée à un
niveau supérieur car l'homme est prêt à
se laisser blesser voir tuer par lui
donc la corrida est un art parce qu'elle
met en scène énormément de nuances et de
référence culturelles historique
traditionnel philosophique et humaniste
bien sûr je ne peux pas résumer en
quelques secondes mais ce que je puis
vous garantir dans le respect de
Monsieur Caron et de tous les gens qui
critiquent la corrida je puis vous
garantir que nous qui aimons la corrida
sommes totalement animés par des
références humaines optimales le respect
du Taureau est total
merci merci à vous pour cette
intervention de depuis Madrid réponse de
d'Aymeric Caron cette intervention vous
êtes directement adressée elle est très
intéressante parce que je pense que
l'été spectateurs pourront juger par
eux-mêmes je sais pas s'il faut que je
rajoute beaucoup ce qu'on a entendu
c'est un galimatias
un verbiage pseudo intellectuel pour
donner du vernis à une pratique immonde
je crois que franchement ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui ont un minimum de raison
ne peuvent pas se laisser avoir par ce
genre de d'arguments qui ne tiennent
absolument pas de respect et une
activité économique très limitée ça ne
vous convainc pas nous avons le respect
du taureau mais quand on respecte un
être
on le met pas à mort il faut arrêter
maintenant enfin vraiment ces excuses
c'est faribole qui n'ont plus aucun sens
et je rebondirai puisque monsieur Casas
dit que ce n'est pas un combat mais vous
recherchez des animaux combatifs donc il
y a un moment il y a une contradiction
aussi dans les propos et d'ailleurs la
corrida est une contradiction permanente
l'année dernière on voit une loi où on
renforce les sanctions pénales sur les
actes de cruauté et tout le monde
applaudit des deux mains et sur le
galère les actes de cruauté allez Jean
René Cazeneuve vous allez avoir un peu
de temps parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup
d'arguments anti corrida allez prenez le
temps de répondre
on peut pas s'acheter une bonne
conscience sur la condition animale en
supprimant la corridence s'acheter une
bonne ce serait trop facile ce serait
trop facile je peux vous dire que
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui n'ont pas le soir recevoir
là-dessus parce que c'est notre majorité
qui a voté l'année dernière vous avez
fait allusion et vous étiez très
favorable à la loi de tout en fait pour
protéger les animaux et nous sommes très
conscients du bien-être animal il faut
juste mettre les choses en place on
parle là de 800 à 1000 taureaux de
combat alors que nous les hommes en
France nous mangeons 3 millions
d'animaux tous les jours et si on veut
s'adresser adresser le sujet de la
conditionnement de la protection de la
qualité il y a 1000 sujets sur les
animaux domestiques sur les chiens sur
les chats errants il y a des mille
sujets qui sont de mon point de vue bien
plus prioritaire que de montrer du doigt
cette pratique culturelle et ancestrale
il faut le dire et donc moi je suis pas
dupe si vous voulez c'est le faner
effectivement de gens qui veulent
interdire le foie gras qui veulent
interdire demain la viande monsieur
karaoké
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça en gros
l'interdiction de la corrida c'est la
porte ouverte à toutes les combats
antispéciste à commencer par la chasse
la pêche etc
aux entreprises qui est obligé à nouveau
là à nouveau de faire des attaques à
personne c'est-à-dire de s'adresser à ma
personne pour essayer de faire croire à
ceux qui nous regardent que le problème
c'est moi non le problème c'est votre
conscience
et oui mais que vous ayez besoin de vous
cacher derrière moi
est-ce que vous avez écrit vous ayez
besoin de vous cacher derrière ma
personnalité pour ne pas assumer le fait
que vous n'osez pas voter l'abolition de
la corrida pour préserver des petits
intérêts électoralistes mais pas du tout
puisque c'est petit vous aviez prouvé
que les Français étaient majoritairement
contre donc si on était dans une logique
electoraliste on se précipiterait pour
voter votre loi vous faites de
l'électoralisme moi je des fois la
culture
vous étiez aujourd'hui un député
vraiment conscient de l'importance de ce
que vous avez à faire dans l'hémicycle
vous auriez à cœur de mettre la loi en
conformité avec la volonté populaire et
d'associer votre voix à celle de ceux
qui vont voter pour l'abolition de la
coda comme le vol 9 Français sur 10
c'est une priorité
faisant des sondages
ni personne sur ce plateau
dans ma réponse à Monsieur Cazeneuve
c'est pas une priorité dites vous avez
complètement raison lorsque vous dites
qu'en effet le nombre d'individus tu es
chaque année dans les arènes est faible
comparé à d'autres pratiques c'est vrai
on est à peu près à 1000 par an sans
doute un peu plus mais mon 1000 et c'est
vrai vous avez rappelé 3 millions
d'animaux qui ont tués dans un abattoir
chaque jour jour en France c'est
beaucoup trop c'est ça sans doute que
vous étiez en train de sous-entendre non
chez vous ah d'accord ok non mais vous
savez
vous venez de dire c'est instinct qu'il
faudrait s'attaquer en priorité
sauf que c'est une priorité parce que
symboliquement ce qui se joue là est
très fort c'est-à-dire que on est
nous arrivons enfin à acter le fait
qu'on ne peut plus autoriser une
activité qui est reconnue comme une
séance de torture publique une exécution
publique ce sera c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé ma loi comme ça un petit pas pour
l'animal 1000 seulement certes mais un
grand pas pour l'humanité en fait cette
fois faut la voter pour nous pour nous
les humains pour ce que ça va dire
si ce texte est à l'ordre du jour il y a
un long processus législatif le Sénat
doit aussi voter ce texte et c'est pas
gagné donc quelque chose me dit qu'on va
on va se revoir sur ce sujet merci merci
d'avoir joué le jeu du débat et merci à
vous aussi mon cadas depuis Madrid merci
à vous on va accueillir à présent notre
grand témoin elle est philosophe et elle
s'attaque dans son dernier livre à la
question
omniprésente de l'identité notre époque
se fourvoie dans un nouvel ordre
identitaire qu'est-ce que ça signifie on
pose la question à Juliette Funès qui
publie le siècle des égarés aux éditions
de l'Observatoire juste après
l'invitation signé ce soir par Marion
Becker regardez
si on vous invite Julia de Funès c'est
pour votre nouvel essai le siècle des
égarés une réflexion philosophique sur
l'identité ou plus précisément sur le
piège identitaire dans lequel la société
est en train de tomber mais au fait
qu'est-ce que l'identité vous essayez de
dresser les contours ou plutôt les
enjeux de ce concept indéfinissable et
de ses pièges parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'identité nationale or c'est
indéfinissable si vous ne demandez ce
que c'est si je vous demande autour de
la table parce que c'est que l'identité
nationale j'aurais autant de définition
que de personnes derrière la salle
quelqu'un va me dire bah c'est Michel
Sardou c'est le château de la Loire
c'est le gaullisme la Tour Eiffel tout
ce que vous voulez c'est indéfinissable
donc je ne crois pas que l'Union
nationale soit possible à partir d'une
identité nationale l'identité c'était
l'objet de votre thèse vous la petite
fille de Louis de Funès devenue
philosophe vous êtes titulaire d'un
doctorat en philosophie mais aussi un
diplôme en management des ressources
humaines après un début de carrière
comme chasseuse de tête vous revenez à
vos premières amours vous partagez votre
vision de l'entreprise par le prisme de
la philosophie dans Socrate au pays des
process ou la Comédie humaine
après avoir dénoncé le narcissisme des
réseaux sociaux et démonter les
mécanismes du développement personnel
vous vous attaquez cette fois au
dogmatisme identitaire
vous voyez ce renforcer les crispations
identitaires et le communautarisme vous
prenez l'exemple du mouvement wok qui
selon vous loin de déconstruire les
identités traditionnelles ne fait
qu'affermir et renforcer les
particularismes si les causes du
mouvement peuvent être légitimes vous
dénoncer son intransigence comment
parvenir au sentiment de soi sans tomber
dans le piège identitaire c'est la
question que vous posez dans votre livre
Julia de Funès alors avez-vous trouvé la
réponse
bonsoir Julia de Funès et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation le
siècle des égarés donc aux éditions de
l'Observatoire attention au piège de
l'identité qui nous égarent plutôt qui
nous oriente alors avant de répondre à
la question qui vous est adressé comment
se chercher sans tomber dans ce piège
savoir qui l'on est quel appartenance
qu'est-ce que l'identité parce que vous
renvoyez à la définition du
concept qui repose sur quasiment rien
qui est indéfinissable je me suis amusé
dans le livre à le comparer à ce que
ceux avec quoi on le compare on la
compare généralement la culture
l'enracinement le corps vous pouvez
prendre une carte d'identité ne dit
absolument rien de vous si je dis votre
carte d'identité je sais pas qui vous
êtes donc vous avez une expression très
forte vous dites qu'on a basculé dans un
ordre
identitaire alors ça c'est ça heurte
parce que on est quoi soumis sous le
joug d'un ordre identitaire c'est notre
civilisation comment on en arrive là un
ordre je l'entends vraiment au sens
construction reconstruction parce qu'on
dit souvent que ces mouvements
identitaires
proviennent de la déconstruction c'est
déjà un peu contestable et surtout si on
regarde dans le dans le détail ce qu'ils
font c'est une reconstruction radicale
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a de plus en plus
de label identitaire de catégories
identitaire et c'est en ce sens que
c'est un nouvel ordre c'est-à-dire que
c'est presque une idéologie au sens
étymologique du terme c'est-à-dire qu'à
partir de l'idée d'identité on repense
toute notre réalité le cinéma les opéras
l'entreprise euh
le la langue l'écriture inclusive le
signe LG voilà le exactement on en finit
pas de de s'allonger donc vous voyez
bien que c'est un nouvel ordre parce que
toutes les sphères de notre société sont
repensées à l'aune de ce principe
identitaire alors là vous donner des
exemples de ce qu'on appelle le Woking
justement cette idéologie ou oui
doctrine disons-nous venus de la
déconstruction venue des États-Unis qui
des couples la société en identité
blessée
ça vient plutôt de la gauche c'est ça
qui vous agace le plus on peut il y a de
l'identité dans le nationalisme
d'extrême droite aussi bien sûr et la
notion d'identité était préentée par la
droite historiquement c'est plutôt une
notion de droite évidemment et là ce qui
est intéressant c'est que maintenant
elle est complètement véhiculée à gauche
aussi à travers ces mouvements là mais
dans ces mouvements là c'est pas une
critique radicale du wokisme mais il y a
des il y a des causes il y a des
revendications qui sont tout à fait
légitime parce que quand on est blanc on
ne se rend pas forcément compte des
systèmes de pouvoir insoupçonnés donc il
y a des codes dans notre société qui
peuvent être encore des systèmes de
pouvoir
insidieux donc je comprends certaines
causes on peut avoir la pensée élargie
se dire c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas
concerné par un problème que le problème
n'existe pas donc il y a des causes
légitimes mais il faut faire la
différence entre les causes légitimes
les revendications légitimes et
l'idéologie intransigeante et très
souvent ces mouvements-là basculent
dérivent après vers une idéologie
intransigeante et les émancipateurs
finissent par être sans soeur et ils
prennent pourtant la tolérance en
prétexte justement pour bien comprendre
ce concept d'identité et la manière dont
il peut être utilisé voire
instrumentaliser dans des idéologies
notamment l'idéologie walkiste vous
faites la distinction
notamment quand on parle des victimes de
l'offense et du préjudice et vous dites
attention il faut distinguer ces deux
notions expliquer nous absolument
j'essaye dans le livre de montrer des
nuances qui permettent d'éclaircir les
situations et de pas faire d'un débat un
combat une guerre et effectivement quand
tout est centré sur l'identité la
moindre offense la moindre vexation
devient un préjudice à l'intégrité de la
personne et donc tout débat devient un
combat et c'est terrible donc il y a une
différence entre
interdire les comportements
préjudiciaires qui créent des préjudices
à l'intégrité de la personne ça c'est un
devoir c'est un droit c'est ce que fait
la justice et rendre imposer des limites
pour rendre les comportements conformes
à des attentes particulières c'est là
qu'on bascule dans l'intransigence
idéologique vous voyez quand les hommes
on a beaucoup par exemple des hommes par
exemple qui sifflent les femmes qui
draguent les femmes dans la rue pour
certaines femmes c'est un préjudice une
atteinte à leur intégrité parce que je
peux tout à fait comprendre pour
d'autres femmes c'est plutôt flatteur
c'est même un hommage c'est c'est même
pas forcément une offense mais légiférer
pour rendre tous les comportements
masculins conformes à des susceptibilité
particulière et individuel là on tombe
dans de l'intransigence alors comment on
fait pour ne pas tomber dans ce piège la
quête de soi c'est la quête d'une vie
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs collective dans
les communautés ou individuelles la
religion la foi est-ce que cette quête
là a encore du sang face à ce piège bien
sûr moi il s'agit pas de dire que cette
quête là n'a pas de sens mais je trouve
et j'essaye de penser c'est un essai
c'est une tentative dire que le
sentiment de soi quand est-ce qu'on a le
sentiment d'être véritablement soi-même
que le Soi soit individuel ou collectif
à l'échelle d'une nation c'est
certainement pas en passant par
l'assignation identitaire quand est-ce
que vous vous sentez-vous même c'est
quand vous agissez à partir de vous-même
quand vous êtes libre la plupart du
temps donc je montre que c'est à travers
certaines émotions et notamment à
travers la liberté qu'on parvient au
sentiment de soi l'émotion c'est plus
proche finalement que si je prends
d'identité si je prends le sentiment
d'un nous collectif quand est-ce que un
pays fait vraiment union nationale c'est
pas à partir d'une identité nationale
qui est indéfinissable si je vous
demande quelle est l'identité de la
France vous allez me dire peut-être le
gaullisme j'en sais rien la Tour Eiffel
l'élégance française je vais vous dire
bah non c'est peut-être les châteaux de
la Loire les bons fromages bon on y
arrivera jamais donc c'est pas à partir
du norme d'un idéal normatif d'identité
nationale qu'on va unir le pays mais
c'est toujours à partir d'une émotion
qu'une union secrète malheureusement une
guerre créée un sentiment de peur une
émotion de peur et va unifier le pays
mais une fierté on écoute la
Marseillaise ça peut évoquer ça peut
réveiller un sentiment de fierté un
sentiment d'appartenance une grande
victoire
donc c'est beaucoup plus par ces
émotions là et par la conscience des
émotions que on crée un sentiment
collectif plutôt que par une identité
nationale hasardeuse donc on n'est pas
condamné à rester égaré pour terminer
pour la liberté et j'essaye de tracer
des chemins pour se trouver soi-même se
trouver à l'échelle collective et je
crois pas que ce soit nécessaire de
passer par l'identité qui est plutôt une
dérive merci beaucoup
de l'Observatoire je propose de rester
avec nous trois affran ce soir vont nous
rejoindre trois parties pris et si on a
un arrêté avec Hanouna et ben c'est
Marco pommier qui a posé la question au
député qui soit habitués du plateau de
C8 après les insultes de l'animateur
contre l'insoumis Louis Boyard et puis
on aura le regard de Vincent Vincent
Hugo qui nous parle de Donald Trump ce
soir en route probablement vers une
troisième candidature à la Maison
Blanche et puis les villes de demain
avec efcheftel seront-elles moins
bétonnées pour sauver le climat bonsoir
à vous les affranchis et merci d'être là
Marco une question ce soir des
politiques doivent-ils boycotter les
missions de Cyril Hanouna Touche pas à
mon poste après toutes ces polémiques
après l'altercation violente entre Louis
Boyard et Cyril Hanouna les insultes et
j'en passe oui Myriam l'indignation ne
retombe toujours pas dans les rangs de
la France insoumise on ne parle pas
comme ça à un député lancer hier soir
Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors les politiques
doivent-ils continuer de se rendre dans
Touche pas à mon poste on a posé la
question aujourd'hui ça peut vous
paraître curieux Myriam mais c'était
presque mission impossible de trouver un
élu insoumis appelant au boycott écoutez
manuel Bompard
faut arrêter d'aller dans cette émission
bah c'est pas ma position en tout cas
enfin en tout cas je trouve que le sujet
qui est posé aujourd'hui c'est pas
celui-là c'est pas aux différentes
personnalités de considérer que parce
que les médias fonctionnent mal ils
doivent plus y aller c'est trop facile
de poser la question comme ça voilà pas
de boycott officiellement en tout cas
car officieusement certains élus à la
France insoumise reconnaissent qu'il y a
un débat mais il n'a pas encore été
tranchée la question c'était déjà posée
pour cnews car le problème est bien là
si les élus insoumis boycottent toutes
les chaînes du groupe Bolloré alors il
réduisent considérablement leur audience
raison pour laquelle la France insoumise
ils sont les bienvenus il y a d'autres
antennes raison pour laquelle du coup la
France insoumise propose une loi de
déconcentration des médias dans sa niche
parlementaire discuter depuis ce matin
en commission c'est vrai qu'on a vu
énormément de responsables politiques de
tout bord tous les parties des fils à
Touche pas à mon poste oui ça ne vous a
pas échappé Myriam alors c'est le cas de
Louis Boyard d'Alexis Corbière de Raquel
Garrido pour la France insoumise mais
pratiquement tous les parties sont
concernés vous le disiez y compris le
gouvernement Marlène Schiappa par
exemple assume totalement d'avoir son
ronde serviette à la table de Cyril
Hanouna hier soir encore malgré la
séquence sidérante de jeudi dernier on
pouvait voir les députés Carlo live ou
Julien audoul on est allé les voir
aujourd'hui regardez
pourquoi on devrait boycoter une
émission qui laisse toutes les idées
toutes les opinions s'exprimer librement
et surtout qui permet à bon nombre de
Français
à s'intéresser à la politique boycotter
c'est pas une réponse la preuve c'est
qu'il y a encore il y a plus de 2
millions de personnes qui ont regardé
touchent pas à mon poste donc il y a une
cible vous l'avez compris Myriam Touche
pas à mon poste pour les politiques
c'est une cible c'est le moyen de
toucher un public pas forcément politisé
quand on va chez Hanouna on sait où on
met les pieds c'est sûr que c'est pas la
Chaîne Parlementaire plaisanter un
député de la majorité parfois c'est bien
fermer sa différence alors n'y a-t-il
aucune limite à la dictature de
l'audience du clash et du buzz pour les
politiques le risque c'est d'entrer dans
un engrenage sans fin toujours plus de
clash pour être vu entendu un député des
républicains me disait dans Touche pas à
mon poste on vote avec des pancartes sur
des sujets polémiques ce sont des
discussions de comptoir c'est pas à la
de la politique bref les politiques
doivent-ils se rendre chez Cyril Hanouna
c'est tout le débat mais peut-être
peut-être est-il temps de dire stop
merci beaucoup Marco pommier vous
regardez de temps en temps touche pas
mon poste d'identité aussi d'ailleurs
dans cette émission il y a quand même
effectivement chaque communauté très
représentée mais bon dès qu'on est les
uns à côté des autres et qu'on est dans
une émission on joue un rôle donc c'est
ça est-ce que le rôle qu'on joue est
véritablement proche de la personne
qu'on est c'est cool ou dangereux
c'est ce que j'essaie de montrer dans le
livre c'est-à-dire que le rôle qu'on
joue parfois nous formate nous déguise
on le voit très clairement dans ce type
d'émission ou ailleurs et nous éloigne
une dissimule à nous-mêmes complètement
parfois bon ben on verra ce qu'il en est
cette émission qui a quelque chose
peut-être de lien de connecter avec la
personnalité dont on va parler Donald
Trump ce soir Vincent bonsoir alors
nouvelle candidature à la Maison Blanche
très très probable ancien président a
promis une très grande annonce malgré
son score médiocre ou le score médiocre
de des poules à républicains en mitter
sera l'une des journées les plus
importantes de l'histoire des États-Unis
étranges accès de modestie pourquoi
diable l'une des journées et non la
journée la plus mémorable dans cette
tour d'horloge donc est sauf coup de
théâtre le bout de feu ira cible
annoncera en sa vie la floridienne et
sous les vivades c'est disciples sac
candidature à la présidentielle de 2024
il sera 21h à Mara Lago temple du kitsch
plaqué or et 3h du matin chez nous en
clair un horaire taillé sur mesure pour
les insomniaques et les fans de la NBA
alors ceux qui ne sont ni insomniaques
ni fans de la NBA
vont-ils se lever en pleine nuit pas su
urgent doute au regard des ombres
susceptibles de ternir l'éclat de ce
triomphe romain le cador de l'immobilier
espérait donc surfer sur la vague géante
républicaine promise à la veille des
élections de mi-mandat et sur le succès
éclatant de ses poulains les plus ailés
ratés en fait de tsunami un clapotis le
Sénat reste démocrate la chambre pour
des représentants ne le sera plus mais
la majorité du Grand hoop partit ici
avait plus étriqué qu'escompté et puis
voilà que car il est une ancienne icône
de Fox News si fière de son surnom de
Trump en jupon triomphe du féministe
mort la poussière en Arizona où elle
brille le fauteuil de gouverneur son
mentor menteur aurait-il troqué sa toge
de gourou contre un pelage de Chat Noir
Le Parrain serait-il devenu boulet pas
si vite car l'ex-président garde un
socle électoral robuste il a encore dans
l'optique de l'investiture républicaine
la faveur des sondages mais le vent
tourne ah oui alors à quoi on le voit
quels sont les signes de cette nouvelle
donne les médias de l'empire Murdoch
lâchent je cite un looser qui mène les
siens de fiasco en fiasco ils ont
désormais les yeux de Chimène pour le
gouverneur de Floride De Santis un cadra
ultra conservateur Ron versus donne
c'est vrai que la fiche aurait du chien
il n'empêche plus d'un castigle du parti
juge l'heure de la retraite venue pour
l'aîné des deux cible au passage de
plusieurs enquêtes de judiciaires que
celle-ci porte sur sa gestion au milieu
des volts des archives de la maison
blanche ou plus graves sur son rôle dans
l'assaut du Capitole le 6 janvier 2021
c'est d'ailleurs ce mardi que sortent
les mémoires de son
président
pour échapper à la vindicte des insurgés
lui qui refusa de saborder la
certification de la victoire de Biden et
accuse aujourd'hui Trump d'avoir mis en
danger sa vie et celle de sa famille et
ça ça peut ébranler le noyau dur d'être
un piste non je ne crois pas mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut difficilement oublier
pour autant que le forcenet de Mara Lago
a conquis ses gallons de stars on y
revient sous les sunlights d'une
émission de téléréalité ça lancée en
2004 par la chaîne NBC une nappe
compétition mettant au prise des
candidats à un poste de cadres sup à
mi-chemin entre l'entretien d'embauche
et les jeux du cirque comment oublier
surtout la délectation cruelle avec
laquelle l'animateur de ce barnum Trump
soi-même éliminait Anna les postulants
you are fire vous êtes viré on se prend
à rêver
de ce show Donald vous avez mis en péril
la démocratie américaine vous avez à
coup de mensonges et de menaces avilie
ces institutions vous avez conduit ce
pays au bord de la guerre civile
tonalefire merci Vincent Vincent jeux et
sa plume acerée dans chaque chronique
alors ce soir avec FCF tel de libération
on va revenir à l'occasion de la cop27
qui s'achève à Charmel Cheikh en Egypte
cette semaine sur un matériau
pas très connu enfin si quand même mais
plutôt discret dont on parle peu le
béton que qui a l'air inoffensif comme
ça par rapport au plastique ou à
d'autres et le béton il est partout
c'est quand même le deuxième matériau le
plus utilisé après l'eau et depuis les
années 50 il a littéralement conquis
toute la surface de la terre
car il y a plusieurs raisons il est bon
marché déjà il est facile à fabriquer il
faut mélanger du sable en gros du
gravier du ciment avec un peu d'eau et
puis s'adapte à tous les usages du grand
barrage comme en Chine les Trois Gorges
jusqu'à la petite auto-construction dans
un bidonville donc il est un peu pour
tous le béton démocratique exactement
mais en même temps le béton émet plus de
CO2 que l'aviation à cause du ciment
notamment qu'il faut chauffer à 1400
degrés il est responsable de 4 à 8% des
émissions mondiales de CO2 en gros seul
le pétrole le charbon et le gaz font
pire donc c'est pas bon pour le climat
mais c'est pas bon pour l'environnement
non plus le béton alors exactement comme
l'a montré justement le philosophe
hansenjab j'ai amené son son livre
philosophe radical d'extrême gauche dans
son livre béton armes de construction
massive du capitalisme aux éditions
l'échapper le béton contribue à
l'uniformisation du monde à la réduction
de sa richesse et de sa diversité il va
même jusqu'à dire qu'il a assassiné les
architectures traditionnelles ah oui
alors donc c'est un peu comme si on
parlait de Coca-Cola pour les traditions
culinaires oui c'est un peu un sort de
Coca-Cola du BTP il a aussi défiguré si
vous voulez paysages les littéraux on a
qu'à penser au saccage de des côtes
méditerranéennes en Espagne en Italie en
France même et ce béton a aussi engendré
un mode de vie très énergivore parce que
comme les immeubles qui sont construits
dans ce matériau sont sont une faible
performance énergétique du coup on a
inventé des isolants et puis la
climatisation dont on sait très bien
passé pendant pendant tout le temps la
solution est-ce qu'il existe des
alternatives il y en a et puis les
industriels sont sans réclament le béton
bas carbone tous les grands projets
aujourd'hui sont faits en béton bas
carbone mais le capitalisme vert n'y
croient pas lui il dit c'est comme si on
demandait un loup de devenir végétarien
pour lui il faut carrément laisser
tomber le béton et privilégier la pierre
qui est plus chère mais plus durable
parce que contrairement à une idée reçue
le la durée de vie d'une construction en
béton armé et assez limité entre 30 et
50 ans c'est pourquoi le béton pour lui
et le matériau par excellence du
capitalisme et il incarne sa fameuse
obsolescence programmée donc on est bon
à revenir la niche c'est ça les fameuses
lampes à huiles alors en fait pas du
tout et Anselme Japon invite à repenser
complètement nos façons de vivre à nous
interroger en fait sur l'utilité la
valeur des choses il nous dit de quoi
avons-nous vraiment besoin ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut complètement renoncer à
tout mais par exemple on nous dit tout
le temps il faut qu'on soit des nouveaux
logements du neuf etc mais en fait il y
a déjà plein d'immeubles vides et la
croissance démographique on le sait on
va atteindre 8 milliards
et ensuite va marquer le pas donc pas
forcément on n'a pas forcément besoin de
construire de nouveau bien bon ben
écoutez j'ai appris plein de choses vous
saviez que non
pas du tout mais c'est toujours la même
chose c'est-à-dire que j'ai pas lu le
livre donc je juge pas du tout mais on a
une approche de l'écologie vraiment des
croissante à chaque fois donc on se mais
avec quoi on va vivre puis il y a plus
de plastique il y a plus de béton je
préfère la pierre esthétiquement je
préfère aussi la pierre mais je trouve
que c'est dommage dans notre pays de
décorer les toujours l'écologie de
l'économie je crois plus que ce c'est
pas l'innovation qu'on va
progresser parce qu'une économie qui
s'occupe pas d'écologie effectivement
elle est insensée
sans école écologie sans économie elle
est impuissante donc je trouve que c'est
un peu dommage toujours de penser
l'écologie sur le mode de la
décroissance et la période que l'on vit
une époque voilà extrêmement
conflictuelle et très très difficile
tellement les défis sont importants elle
est propice à la pensée philosophique on
a le défi climatique on nous parle
d'apocalypse on est dans la guerre la
matière à penser même si c'est
merveilleux c'est dramatique c'est
tragique mais c'est un peu comme les
médecins qui réussissent parce que vous
êtes malade la philosophie effectivement
fait feu tout bois et là on a une
période assez riche pour pour penser à
prendre à penser et à nuancer aussi
certaines idées pensez de Donald Trump
pour ville de demain en passant par
Cyril Hanouna c'est un joli mot de la
fin Vincent oui moi j'ai une double
obsession depuis quelques années qui
s'est construite au fil de mes
reportages notamment en Afrique au
Moyen-Orient c'est d'abord l'assignation
identitaire ce qui m'apporte et non pas
ce que tu dis où tu écris mais ce que tu
es et ça je pense que c'est une défaite
de la pensée en campagne et puis les
stérilisation du débat dont Cyril
Hanouna est une incarnation caricaturale
on va s'arrêter là merci et les deux
sont liés et les deux sont liés
l'identité et l'histérisations
Juliette Funès le siècle des égarés
s'est oséditions l'Observatoire merci à
vous les affranchis vous êtes les
bienvenus quand vous voulez vous le
savez très belle soirée documentaire qui
commence maintenant avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à demain